los artistas cubanos que antes se
subieron a escenario se inauguraron
galerías de arte mike el castillo y luís
manuel otero alcántara ahora se sientan
en el banquillo de los acusados en la
habana aunque ambos ya llevan meses
entre rejas por participar en la
organización de varias protestas en el
conocido movimiento de san isidro
bien
soy
tengo un sentimiento maternal con él y
él conoce
y este es un momento verdaderamente
importante en la vida
otero está acusado de difamación de la
bandera nacional desacato y desorden
público y se enfrenta a 7 años de cárcel
mientras que castillo también ha sido
acusado por agresión por lo que podría
enfrentar una pena de hasta 10 años
varios diplomáticos internacionales
intentaron ir al juicio en calidad de
observadores pero no obtuvieron
respuesta del gobierno
pero oficial en nombre de la unión
europea
pero hasta el momento no hemos visto los
derechos humanos básicos en nuestra
opinión es la libre libertad el derecho
a la expresión libre el derecho hacer
yunier libremente tanto la opinión
internacional como diferentes
organizaciones como human rights watch
han mostrado su apoyo y solidaridad con
los dos artistas
el gobierno de cuba debe liberar de
inmediato y sin condiciones a los
artistas mike el castillo pérez y luís
manuel otero alcántara sin embargo en la
esfera nacional además del propio
gobierno cubano algunos dudan sobre las
intenciones de otero alcántara por actos
como fotografiarse con la bandera de
cuba para ir al baño en el pasado el
gobierno cubano dijo que los imputados
actuaron como agentes de eeuu para
provocar agitación social